I don't think that Facebook or or
Internet Platforms in general should be
Arbiters of truth I think that's a kind
of a dangerous line to get down to in
terms of deciding what is what is true
and what isn't Facebook's products harm
children Stoke Division and weaken our
democracy
the company's leadership knows how to
make Facebook and Instagram safer but
won't make the necessary changes because
they have put their astronomical profits
before people General you want to give
as wide of a voice possible and I think
you want to have a special deference to
political speech hi there I'm Jenny Luna
a multimedia producer at Stanford
Graduate School of Business and I'm
Kelsey Doyle also a producer here at the
GSB and you're listening to Facebook and
political speech we've taken a written
Case by political economy Professor Ken
Schatz and case writer Sheila Melvin and
turn it into what we're calling a pod
case
yeah this podcast is designed for use in
classes on business ethics or
corporations in society to discuss the
social responsibility of business
as you're listening questions may arise
for you like how should social media
balance a commitment to freedom of
speech with the need to prevent violence
and civil unrest when is censorship okay
if ever
and what role should government play if
any in legislating how internet
companies regulate what elected
officials can say in their platforms to
dive deeper into these questions Jenny
and I will dig into Facebook's history
particularly in U.S politics and examine
how it's navigated contentious decisions
about political speech in an
ever-evolving digital landscape the pod
case won't be a comprehensive overview
of Facebook and elections in the U.S or
anywhere else it's really meant to see
how you respond to it what is your moral
reaction and how is it different from
others who hear the same thing
we're excited to guide you through this
auditory experience you can find a link
to the written case study via our
website gsb.stanford.edu
[Music]
when a college student named Mark
Zuckerberg created a website called the
Facebook back in 2004 he had no idea it
would eventually become the world's
largest social media company
with around 3 billion users sharing 140
billion messages and a billion stories a
day Facebook has changed the way humans
communicate and relate to one another
more than 80 percent of adult social
media users in the United States
reported visiting Facebook at least once
a week in 2022 and the platform's global
penetration was nearly 40 percent
[Music]
Facebook's original mission statement
was making the world more open and
connected
as the audience at the 2010 all things D
conference found out company founder
Mark Zuckerberg even wore it inside his
trademark hooded sweatshirt
it is a warm hoodie yeah no it's a thick
hoodie we it's um it's a company hoodie
we print our mission on the inside what
oh really the inside of the hoodie
everybody take a moment what is it
making the making the world more open
and connected oh my God it's like a
secret fault
[Applause]
but in 2017 Zuckerberg announced a
change
the idea behind our new mission
is to bring the world closer together
[Music]
and the full formal mission statement is
going to be to give people the power to
build community to bring the world
closer together
[Music]
the Facebook company which nowadays is
named Meta also includes Instagram and
WhatsApp
combined meta's apps are used by over
200 million businesses
on The Meta website the company's
principles are to quote give people a
voice build connection and Community
Serve everyone keep people safe and
protect privacy promote Economic
Opportunity
meta's primary source of Revenue is
advertising
connecting people bringing them closer
together with economic pressure to make
sure that users engage with the site and
generate revenue for advertisers
balancing these sometimes competing
missions and business requirements has
been a difficult tightrope for meta to
walk
Facebook and meta have been accused of
bias and censorship of helping ferment
violence and fuel genocide and of
tipping the balance of national
elections in many ways the rise of
Facebook's influence is the story of how
the internet became the most powerful
political tool on Earth
please welcome President Clinton and
Senator Dole
[Music]
the 1996 U.S presidential campaign first
that incorporated the World Wide Web as
it was known back then
only 20 million American adults had
access to the internet at the time
mostly through dial-up modems
the New York Times suggested that the
web presences of both the Republican and
Democratic campaigns were quote partly
marketing gestures intended to emphasize
that their candidates are men of the
future at ease with modern technology
this election is important
I ask for your support I ask for your
help
if you really want to get involved
just tap into my home page
www.dollcamp96.org
thank you God bless America
Republican Presidential candidate Bob
Doles for getting the dot before org
showed just how new the internet was for
most people nonetheless longtime
journalist Marvin called predicted that
the web would play a growing role in
politics he wrote in an uncensored Open
Access medium where everyone can have a
say everyone will have a say in one way
or another what people will say will be
opinionated and partisan it will play
fast and loose with the facts and it
will largely be undocumented much of the
web already is information by mob Rule
and that isn't likely to change as this
decentralized medium becomes more and
more populated
eight years later Howard Dean a
candidate for the 2004 Democratic
presidential nomination was generally
considered the first politician to make
effective use of the web his followers
connected through meetup.com and his
campaign staff embraced a decentralized
work structure five thousand strong the
most volunteers ever to come out and
help on a caucus so this is the crew
that you guys will be seeing a lot of
this is Ken sanguin who's directing the
effort right here
[Applause]
we're going to have training for the
Iowa caucus for Iowans want to learn
about it there'll be video showing them
exactly what they're going to do with
the caucus so they're not scared of it
and they have a good time and help Dean
win we're going to have you know places
for people to come in log in find out
how they're going to get to Iowa there's
going to be a ride board so people can
organize trips from all over the country
to come into Iowa it's gonna be awesome
some argue that the internet invented
Dean as a candidate helping the
little-known Vermont Governor soar to
national attention and for a Time be a
serious presidential contender
but the internet may have also led to
Dean's demise a passionate speech after
the Iowa Democratic caucuses ended in
what came to be called the dean scream
we go to South Dakota
in Oregon and Washington and Michigan
and then we're going to Washington D.C
to take back the White House
ah
that scream was ridiculed and became
what many consider the first political
mean oh my god did you see Dean's speech
last night oh my God now I hear the cows
in Iowa afraid of getting mad Deen
disease this land will surely vote for
me as it went viral on the internet and
on TV news coverage of the scream
drowned out Dean's political messages
the 2004 Dean scream coincidentally took
place about two weeks before a 19 year
old Mark Zuckerberg launched the
Facebook on Harvard's campus
politics were not even a consideration
the goal was to let Harvard University
students connect with one another online
but four years later when the 2008
presidential campaign rolled around
Facebook had accumulated 100 million
active users and politicians saw it as a
powerful tool on the campaign Trail
U.S news and World Report underlined the
role that Facebook played in Barack
Obama's 2008 Victory claiming quote
Obama enjoyed a Groundswell of support
among for lack of a better term the
Facebook generation he will be the first
occupant of the White House to have won
a presidential election on the web
the article further noted that Chris
Hughes a Facebook co-founder who left
the company to volunteer for Obama had
quote masterminded the Obama campaign's
highly effective web Blitzkrieg
everything from social networking sites
to podcasting and mobile messaging
part of what
makes for a healthy democracy what is is
a good politics is when you've got
citizens who are informed who are
engaged and what Facebook
allows us to do is make sure this isn't
just a one-way conversation make sure
that uh not only am I speaking to you
but you're also speaking back and we're
in a conversation we're in a dialogue
during the 2010 Congressional elections
Facebook conducted an experiment to
gauge the political influence of its
platform the randomized control trial
sent political mobilization messages to
61 million Facebook users to test the
hypothesis that political Behavior can
spread through an online social network
find your polling place on the U.S
politics page and click the I voted
button to tell your friends you voted
Jamie settle Jason Jones and 13 of your
friends have voted the results which
were published in nature found that the
messages directly influence political
self-express session information seeking
and real-world voting behavior of
millions of people
furthermore the messages not only
influence the users who receive them but
also the user's friends and Friends of
Friends
by the 2012 Presidential election
Facebook had over 1 billion users this
exponential growth the guardian wrote
meant this will be the first election
cycle in which Facebook could become a
dominant political force a major
campaigning tool that has the potential
to transform friendship into a political
weapon Facebook is also being seen as a
source of invaluable data on voters
using its targeted sharing app Obama's
campaign asked supporters to share their
friend lists which most did
here's Betsy Hoover the campaign's
online organizing director being
interviewed on NPR you know we got your
list of friends and then we matched it
to our model our list of Voters that we
didn't build with Facebook data we built
with voter history and you know all of
the other data points that Democratic
campaigns use to build models but we
matched the data of your friends to that
model and then reflected it back to the
person who had authorized the app and
said if you want to reach out to your
friends about this election on Facebook
here are the ones that you should reach
out to First
in 2014 responding to privacy concerns
Facebook began to limit how much
information third-party apps could
collect the shift was lamented by the
industry newsletter campaigns and
elections in an article headlined
Facebook kills a Grassroots tool
nonetheless analysts predicted that
Facebook which had become a major
conduit of news and information would
significantly impact future elections
tarun wadwa riding on HuffPost argued
the design policies and algorithms
chosen by the company are having a major
impact on how elections are run and how
the electorate gets their information
this puts Facebook in an incredibly
powerful position to determine the
political future of the several
countries where it is most popular
whether it wants this responsibility or
not Facebook has now become an integral
part of the democratic process globally
when your kids and grandkids ask what
you did in 2016 when everything was on
the line I hope you'll be able to say
that you voted for a better stronger
fairer America
in 2016 Democratic party presidential
candidate Hillary Clinton was widely
expected to win and did win the popular
vote by 2.8 million votes but Republican
party nominee Donald Trump won the
election with victories in enough states
to earn a 304 to 227 margin in the
Electoral College it's been what they
call a historic
event
but to be really historic we have to do
a great job
and I promise you that I will not let
you down we will do a great job we will
do a great job
I look very much
forward to being your president analysts
from across the political Spectrum
attributed his victory to Facebook for a
number of reasons first and foremost was
the use of the platform for messaging
and advertising Trump's digital media
manager Brad parscale told Wired
Magazine that Facebook helped generate
most of the 250 million dollars that the
campaign raised online and he said that
Facebook and Twitter were the reason we
won this thing Twitter for Mr Trump and
Facebook for fundraising
here's parscale speaking to PBS front
lines James Jacoby we knew that Facebook
the audiences were there the people were
there the people we needed to touch and
there was probably no better way to per
dollar connect with them other than
Facebook and so what was the primary in
the primary season what was the strategy
on Facebook and how did it kind of shift
going into 26. shock and all shock and
all how so what's that mean which means
is uh
put Mr Trump
's message let him speak directly to
camera
and give it to as many people as
possible
and why was Facebook the ideal medium
for that low-cost CPM large numbers of
conservative voters
ability to broadcast all day multiple
times to the same audience and the
numbers were shown in the consumer side
that people were spending more and more
hours of their day consuming Facebook
content and aggregated news feed
[Music]
with the Advent of social media it
became possible to Target advertising
with greater Precision at a lower cost
this ability accelerated after Facebook
ads was launched in 2007.
in reference to the Obama campaign media
analyst Daniel crease wrote that
Facebook provided a wealth of new ways
to Target groups of Voters these ads
were based on a cost per click model
where the campaign only pays when an
individual sees an ad and clicks on it
on Facebook the campaign targeted
Advertising based on a host of different
characteristics revealed on voters
profile pages from political persuasion
and religion to Hobbies
Facebook launched its mobile app in 2011
and in 2012 the platform provided
advertisers the ability to place ads in
users news feeds including on the app in
2013 Facebook launched a feature that
was later renamed metapixel which
enabled advertisers to track conversions
and understand how users interacted with
their brand or campaign both on and off
Facebook it also launched lookalike
audiences algorithmically generated
groups of people most likely to be
interested in whatever someone was
selling as machine learning improved so
did the algorithms used for targeting
readers in 2016 the Trump campaign ran
40 to 50 000 variants of its Facebook
ads daily on the day of the third
presidential debate it ran 175 000 a
technique that Gary Kobe director of
advertising at the Republican National
Committee called a b testing on steroids
the campaign spent 80 percent of its
digital ad Budget on Facebook
Facebook embedded staff to work
alongside the Trump campaign and help
them Target potential donors and voters
the Trump team's key contact at Facebook
encouraged the campaign to run ads that
targeted Facebook users who had liked or
commented on Trump's posts in the
previous month every dollar spent on
such ads yielded the campaign two to
three dollars in donations bringing in
millions in just a few days
the company offered the same services to
the Clinton campaign but found them less
receptive
but it wasn't just advertising
disinformation and so-called fake news
was also on the list of election related
criticism coming Facebook's way around
the time of the 2016 election BuzzFeed
reported that scores of websites focused
on U.S politics were run by teenagers in
Macedonia who had found the best way to
generate shares on Facebook is to
publish sensationalist and often false
content that caters to Trump supporters
the creators of the sites whose goal was
to make money use information from
right-wing American websites to Garner
clicks much of the content was
completely made up like a viral post
claiming that the pope had endorsed
Trump
several days after the election CEO Mark
Zuckerberg appeared at the tachonomy
conference where he addressed claims
that fake news on Facebook had helped
Trump win you know personally
I think the the idea that
you know fake news on Facebook of which
you know it's a very small amount of of
um of the content uh influenced the
election in any way I think is a pretty
crazy idea
um there is a certain
profound lack of empathy in asserting
that the only reason why someone could
have voted the way they did is because
they saw some fake news right I think if
if you believe that then I don't think
you have internalized the message that
Trump supporters are trying to send in
in this election
Zuckerberg later walked back this
statement writing after the election I
made a comment that I thought the idea
that misinformation on Facebook changed
the outcome of the election was a crazy
idea calling that crazy was dismissive
and I regret it this is too important an
issue to be dismissive
yet Zuckerberg argued the data has
always shown that our broader impact
from giving people a voice to enabling
candidates to communicate directly to
helping millions of people vote played a
far bigger role in this election
there was also the issue of Russian
interference
in June 2016 the Democratic National
Committee or DNC announced that had been
attacked by Russian hackers this led
Facebook to investigate whether any
Russian activity had been directed at
the social media site
by November according to the New York
Times Facebook had discovered that
Russian operatives were pushing DNC
leaks and propaganda on the platform
Russia if you're listening I hope you're
able to find the thirty thousand emails
that are missing in February 2018 the
justice department indicted 13 Russian
individuals and three companies for
trying to criminally interfere in the
2016 U.S presidential election this
included the Russian internet research
agency or IRA which allegedly placed ads
on Facebook to promote divisive content
and Stoke political and social unrest
these ads used Facebook targeting tools
to reach narrow groups of users
the IRA created an estimated 470 fake
Facebook accounts some pretending to
belong to activist organizations in the
U.S and use these accounts to influence
or incite people around issues like
racism immigration and lgbtq plus rights
the IRA also bought ads or hosted fake
accounts on Google and Twitter as well
as Pokemon go Tumblr and PayPal Hillary
Clinton is the co-author of Obama's
anti-police and anti-constitutional
propaganda join us because we care black
matters who is behind this mask a man a
woman a terrorist burka as a security
risk and it should be banned on U.S soil
we call for disqualification and removal
of Hillary Clinton from the presidential
ballot as dynastic succession of the
Clinton family in American politics
breaches the core democratic principles
in September 2017 Facebook agreed to
give Congress detailed information on
russian-backed ads improve disclosure
requirements for political ads change
its ad review process and more than
double the size of its election
Integrity team
it is a new challenge for internet
communities to deal with nation states
attempting to subvert elections
Zuckerberg said
but if that's what we must do we are
committed to rising to the occasion
experts disagreed on the impact of the
Russian ads a 2018 Washington Post
analysis for example called the scale of
Russian ads vastly overstated
as Facebook scrambled to make changes
the focus wasn't just on the United
States groups all over the world had
become fully aware of Facebook's ability
to shift people's views and perspectives
on topics far beyond electoral politics
in 2018 it created a 24 7 command center
to Monitor and remove abuses and limit
the spread of hateful or untrue content
by tweaking its algorithms or adding
banners and labels with relevant
authoritative information inside this
war room a team of Facebook analysts
monitor elections around the world
they're looking for fake accounts
suspicious patterns any sign of election
tampering the initial Focus was
elections in Brazil and the U.S but
events in Myanmar formerly known as
Burma had demonstrated that Facebook
could be used for purposes far beyond
electoral politics
Myanmar was ruled by a military Junta
from 1962 to 2011. during that time few
people had cell phones or internet
access when Myanmar began to liberalize
in 2011 mobile adoption was rapid
Facebook initially allowed its app which
came pre-loaded on new phones to be used
without data charges
people who once visited tea shops to get
Word of Mouth news can now get it from
Facebook which one commentator called
the nation's digital tea shop
by 2019 there were an estimated 21
million Facebook users out of a
population of 54 million Facebook
reportedly accounted for 99 of social
media usage and had become a virtual
synonym for internet
beginning in 2013 members of myanmar's
military were believed to have used fake
identities on Facebook to make
incendiary posts about the rohingya the
nation's largest Muslim minority group
the rohingya had long been discriminated
against perceived as illegal immigrants
from Bangladesh even though many could
trace their roots in Myanmar back
centuries they were banned from holding
citizenship or owning land and had to
seek permission in order to marry or
travel
according to reporting in the New York
Times some of the propaganda techniques
used by the military were based on
tactics used in Russia While others were
homegrown
these included Facebook pages and news
Pages ostensibly dedicated to pop stars
and other celebrities that displayed
gruesome photos fake news and
inflammatory charges targeting the
rohingya and democracy activists like
the Nobel Peace Prize winner ansan
tsuchi social media was slow in coming
to Myanmar it's now booming providing
new platforms for figures such as
Buddhist monk Ashen wiritu nature
when he goes on Facebook and calls
rohingya snakes and Mad Dogs he has more
than 400 000 followers who can spread
that across other Platforms in August
2017 the military and Myanmar began a
series of attacks against the rohingya
that included murder rape and torture
human rights groups widely characterized
these attacks as acts of genocide
Villages were raised and thousands
killed leading to The Exodus of nearly a
million rohingya primarily to Bangladesh
but the violence against the Muslim
minority and the resulting exodus by
land and sea are unprecedented and
deadly and Must Be Stopped says the U.S
Secretary General Myanmar must take
determined action to put an end to this
vicious cycle of violence and to provide
security and assistance to all those in
need
UN Human Rights investigators stated
that social media had played a
determining role in these events
marzuki daruzman chairman of the un
independent International fact-finding
mission on Myanmar added that it has
substantively contributed to the level
of acrimony and dissension and conflict
if you will within the public hate
speech is certainly of course a part of
that
as far as the Myanmar situation is
concerned social media is Facebook and
Facebook is social media in August 2018
meta acknowledged that the ethnic
violence in Myanmar is horrific and we
have been too slow to prevent
misinformation and hate on Facebook
the company hired more Burmese language
experts and created better AI tools to
detect posts that broke the rules
Facebook also commissioned an
independent human rights assessment and
published the findings in November 2018.
product policy manager Alex warovka
wrote the report concludes that prior to
this year we weren't doing enough to
help prevent our platform from being
used to filament Division and incite
offline violence we agree that we can
and should do more
according to the Los Angeles Times in
August 2018 Facebook banned 20
individuals and organizations including
myanmar's military Chief and remove
pages that altogether were followed by
almost 12 million people
the company said it was the first time
it had banned a country's military or
political leaders
meanwhile in Brazil Facebook and
WhatsApp were flooded with a tsunami of
fake news during that country's 2018
election
and in the U.S Facebook continued to
uncover ongoing Russian attempts to
influence voters including fake accounts
and identities linked to individuals
associated with past activity by the
Russian internet research agency
the company announced the creation of an
independent oversight board to review
content decisions
the board which began operating in 2020
was to use its independent judgment to
support people's right to free
expression and ensure those rights are
being adequately respected and its
decisions were binding
Facebook also addressed the issue of
political ads and stopped paying sales
commissions to employees selling
political ads and stopped embedding
employees with presidential campaigns
Google and Twitter had also offered
political advertising support to
Republicans and Democrats but according
to an article in the Wall Street Journal
Facebook size and questions about misuse
of data siphon from the platform meant
it took the brunt of the public backlash
in 2018 Facebook launched a searchable
database of political ads and soon
expanded it to include all ads on the
site the company reportedly considered
dropping political advertising
altogether as Twitter opted to do in
October 2019 but Facebook ultimately
didn't do that it did however update its
advertising policies to offer expanded
transparency and more controls over
political ads Rob leatherne Facebook's
director of product management explained
the reasoning by writing on the
company's website unlike Google we have
chosen not to limit targeting of these
ads we consider doing so but through
extensive research and consultations we
heard about the importance of these
tools for reaching key audiences from a
wide range of ngos non-profits political
groups and campaigns including both
Republican and Democratic committees in
the U.S ultimately we don't think
decisions about political ads should be
made by private companies which is why
we are arguing for regulation that would
apply across the industry
in the absence of Regulation Facebook
and other companies are left to design
their own policies we have based ours on
the principle that people should be able
to hear from those who wish to lead them
warts and all and that what they say
should be scrutinized and debated in
public lethern concluded by noting that
all advertisers including politicians
had to abide by the company's Community
standards that ban hate speech harmful
content and content designed to
intimidate voters or stop them from
exercising their right to vote
that policy was soon put to the test
[Music]
in May 2020 George Floyd an unarmed 46
year old black man was murdered by
Minneapolis Police while being arrested
on suspicion of using a counterfeit
twenty dollar bill
during the massive racial Justice
protests that followed president Trump
posted remarks on both Facebook and
Twitter that included the phrase when
the Looting starts the shooting starts
Twitter flagged Trump's post and made it
difficult to share but Facebook kept it
accessible an approach that was
consistent with its practice of allowing
political speech that was newsworthy to
remain on the site even if it otherwise
violated the company's standards major
companies unhappy with Facebook's
decision launch an advertising boycott
and more than 5 000 Facebook employees
denounced the decision
some Facebook employees perform a
virtual walkout choosing not to show up
for work on Monday it's all part of a
protest over CEO Mark Zuckerberg's
decision not to take action against
President Donald Trump's controversial
post referencing violence protests
around the country when Facebook
employees said he disagrees with
Zuckerberg's decision to do nothing
about Trump's recent post and said there
isn't a neutral position on racism in
response to the Uproar over this post
and others in which Trump promoted
falsehoods about covid-19 cares election
fraud and more Facebook announced that
it would remove posts including those by
political leaders that incited violence
or attempted to suppress voting and said
that it would label posts that violated
its policies including on hate speech
closer to the 2020 elections Facebook
implemented break the glass measures or
temporary interventions to keep the
platform safe like slowing down the
growth of political groups that might
spread misinformation and ferment
extremism it also suspended political
and social ads in the week before
Election Day November 3rd Facebook's
election related efforts described by
one former company executive as an
attempt to make sure Facebook wasn't the
story were initially seen as largely
successful
but immediately after Democratic
candidate Joe Biden won the election by
more than 7 million votes and in the
Electoral College Trump and his allies
also declared Victory and spread false
stories claiming the election had been
stolen this is a fraud on the American
public this is an embarrassment to our
country
we were getting ready to win this
election frankly we did win this
election
so our goal now is to ensure the
integrity
for the good of this nation this is a
very big moment
this is a major fraud in our nation
Facebook meanwhile began a previously
planned rollback of the emergency
measures that had helped control toxic
speech and misinformation before
election day
it also dismantled the Civic Integrity
group and redeployed its members to
other teams
guy Rosen Facebook's vice president for
integrity outlined a new structure on
December 2nd 2020 noting we've made
incredible progress in getting problems
under control and many of us looked to
the US 2020 elections as a major
Milestone on this path I am so very
proud of this team and everything we've
accomplished
the success of Facebook's election
related efforts was widely questioned
when thousands of trump supporters
shouting stopped the steal attacked the
U.S Capitol on January 6 2021 trying to
prevent the constitutionally mandated
certification of president-elect Biden's
Victory we're going to walk down to the
Capitol
[Applause]
[Music]
into the capitol many false claims of
election fraud had been shared in
Facebook groups when Facebook tried to
shut these stop the steel groups down
their members just moved to other groups
it was subsequently revealed that
between election day on November 3rd and
January 6th some 650 000 posts in
Facebook groups attacked the legitimacy
of the Biden Victory and many of these
posts aim to incite political violence
there we go
[Applause]
the day after the January 6 Insurrection
Facebook placed an indefinite ban on
post by Donald Trump
we believe the risks of allowing the
president to continue to use our service
during this period are simply too great
Zuckerberg wrote Facebook's oversight
board upheld the suspension but not its
indefinite term
Facebook then said it at two years after
that said Nick Clegg vice president of
global Affairs the company would
evaluate external factors including
instances of violence restrictions on
Peaceful assembly and other markers of
civil unrest Facebook rejected
suggestions that its platform was to
blame for the violent attack on the
capitol in a statement to The Washington
Post the company said the notion that
the January 6 Insurrection would not
have happened but for Facebook is absurd
the former president of the United
States pushed a narrative that the
election was stolen including in-person
a short distance from the Capitol
building that day the responsibility for
the violence that occurred on January 6
lies with those who attacked our capital
and those who encouraged them
foreign Facebook increasingly faced
allegations of censorship and double
standards as it struggled to combat
incendiary and divisive posts we have
evidence of them blacklisting in a lot
of cases conservative news there was a
tremendous bias against conservative
news and content in a favorable bias
towards liberal content there are
instances in which your platforms are
taking a very distinctively partisan
approach and not a neutral one as the
Wall Street Journal wrote in 2021 the
issue sits in the middle of one of the
most sensitive debates around Facebook
activists on the left have been urging
the company to more forcefully block
what they see as harmful content other
activists largely on the right accuse
Facebook of censorship directed at
conservative voices
supporters of trump strongly criticized
Facebook for de-platforming him on the
federalist.com David Marcus argued that
Trump quote did not for example tweet
out to his supporters asking them to
donate to a bail fund for their rioters
as Vice president-elect Kamala Harris
did during the Minneapolis riots
this is a blatant and obvious double
standard Marcus argued that very likely
owing to the progressive bent of the
company itself it disproportionately
hides content from conservative sources
more broadly he argued that Facebook's
product is very powerful it feeds the
news to people all over the world if it
claims simply to be a neutral
Marketplace of ideas it has no
justification in Banning political
speech people deserve an opportunity to
engage in free political discourse not
just a discourse that Zuckerberg thinks
is appropriate Senator Chuck Grassley a
republican from Iowa criticized Facebook
for flagging a Fox News article he
posted in early 2022 it's truly
mind-blowing
that these companies continue to
interfere in free expression
big Tech is silencing everyone they
disagree with
and clearly they see no check
to their power
why does Facebook
and one of its third-party fact checkers
Partners they are
get to make the decision that this news
article is considered false information
that decision should be made by the
American people who should be able to
view that content and decide that fact
for themselves
NYU researchers Paul Barrett and Jay
Grant Sims took issue with claims of
anti-conservative bias by Facebook and
other platforms noting that through the
2020 election Trump and conservative
media Outlets had vastly more engagement
on social media than Biden and liberal
media Outlets they argued that in
connection with the capital Riot
Facebook and Twitter did not censor an
extreme conservative cause but
facilitated it adding that the
post-insurrection bans on Trump
constitute reasonable attempts to
forestall additional violence and avoid
real risks to the workings of American
democracy
once again the world was watching events
in the USA and taking notes activist
tetsuywin compared the company's slow
reaction Myanmar with its handling of
the U.S capital Insurrection saying
quote it took a really long time to
respond but in the U.S it was just days
maybe this is the privilege of living in
a first world country
then on February 1st 2021 less than a
month after the Insurrection at the U.S
Capitol myanmar's military sees power in
a coup and imprisoned the nation's
democratically elected leaders Facebook
declared an emergency on February 11 and
took action including using its
Integrity operations center to quote
bring together subject matter experts
from across the company including
Myanmar Nationals with native language
skills so we can monitor and respond to
any threats in real time
on February 24th Facebook banned the
military from the platform while working
to protect quote political speech that
allows the people of Myanmar to express
themselves and to show the world what is
transpiring inside their country
protesters and activists who oppose the
coup use Facebook to share news and
voice their opposition
[Music]
her name is Francis Haugen that is a
fact that Facebook has been anxious to
know since last month when an anonymous
former employee filed complaints with
federal law enforcement
the complaints say Facebook's own
research shows that it amplifies hate
misinformation and political unrest but
the company hides what it knows on
October 3rd 2021 60 Minutes broadcast a
bombshell interview with a whistleblower
who had been leaking front page news for
weeks
Francis Haugen served as a product
manager on Facebook's Civic
misinformation team from 2019 to 2021.
according to Haugen's personal website
she became increasingly alarmed by the
choices Facebook was making prioritizing
their own profits over Public Safety and
putting people's lives at risk
her decision to blow the whistle on
Facebook Haugen wrote was a last resort
I don't think Facebook ever set out to
intentionally promote
divisive extreme polarizing content I do
think though that they are aware of the
side effects of the choices they have
made around amplification
Haugen left Facebook in May 2021 and
took with her thousands of pages of
internal documents then filed a federal
whistleblowing complaint with the U.S
Securities and Exchange Commission she
also provided these documents to the
Wall Street Journal and Congress the
journal published a series of articles
based on the leaked documents which it
called the Facebook files Haugen
testified before the U.S Senate the
British Parliament and government
agencies regarding the impact of
Facebook's products on society anger and
hate is the easiest way to grow on
Facebook
in her testimony Haugen placed
considerable emphasis on Facebook's
algorithm approach arguing that this lay
at the core of the company's problems
algorithmic bias issues are a major
issue for our democracy the algorithm to
which she referred was a system Facebook
used to determine the position of a post
in each user's news feed the algorithms
are very smart in the sense that they
latch on to things that people want to
continue to engage with and
unfortunately in the case of teen girls
and things like self-harm they develop
these feedback Cycles where children are
using Instagram as to self-soothe but
then are exposed to more and more
content that makes them hate themselves
a complex formula assessed a minimum of
10 000 data points related to both the
user and to each available post to
predict what a specific user was most
likely to engage with
while the algorithm was tailored to each
user it also reflected the company's
overall strategy regarding what to
promote Facebook's own research says
they cannot adequately identify
dangerous content and as a result those
dangerous algorithms that they admit are
picking up the the extreme sentence the
division
they can't protect us from the harms
that they know exist in their own system
for many years Facebook algorithms had
optimized time spent on the site and
thus gave prominence to articles that
people were likely to click on as well
as professionally produced videos
however in 2018 the company made a
significant change which Zuckerberg
described in a post on Facebook writing
the first changes you'll see will be a
news feed where you can expect to see
more from your friends family and groups
as we roll this out you'll see less
public content like posts from
businesses Brands and media
and the public content you see more will
be held to the same standard it should
encourage meaningful interactions
between people Haugen told British
lawmakers that the changes had failed
other critics argued that the post-2018
algorithm prioritized divisive content
Facebook meanwhile insisted in a memo
distributed to employees that academic
research did not support the idea that
Facebook or social media more generally
is the primary cause of polarization
Zuckerberg himself wrote quote the
argument that we deliberately push
content that makes people angry for
profit is deeply illogical we make money
from ads and advertisers consistently
tell us they don't want their ads next
to harmful or angry content
Clegg the Facebook VP told ABC's George
Stephanopoulos that the algorithm
actually made Facebook safer if you
would just sort of across the board
remove the algorithm the first thing
that would happen is that people would
see more not less hate speech more not
less misinformation more not less
harmful content why because those
algorithmic systems precisely are
designed like a great sort of giant spam
filter to identify and deprecate and
downgrade bad content separately Clegg
noted that each person's news feed was
heavily shaped by individual behavior
and that ultimately content ranking is a
dynamic partnership between people and
algorithms on Facebook he said it takes
two to tango
a company statement argued if it were
true that Facebook is the chief cause of
polarization we would expect to see it
going up wherever Facebook is popular it
isn't is a ranking change the source of
the world's divisions no
[Music]
but controversies continue to arise all
over the world and Ethiopia reports
provided to CNN revealed Facebook
employees became concerned that the
company was allowing people to use the
platform to incite violence against
ethnic minorities and one of the
documents taken by Haugen The
Whistleblower was a report based on a
Facebook team's research trip to Europe
the report said that the long-term
health of the company necessitated
revisions to the algorithm likening the
emphasis on outrage generating content
to eating junk food
we can choose to be idle and keep
feeding users fast food but that only
works for so long it said many have
already caught on to the fact that fast
food is linked to obesity and therefore
its short-term value is not worth the
long-term cost
the report cited specific concerns from
Poland after Decades of communist rule
Poland transitioned to democracy in the
1990s
but in 2015 the populist and socially
conservative Law And Justice party came
to power espousing traditional polish
values
in the Facebook teams report political
parties described a social Civil War
online with fierce battle lines drawn on
topics like abortion lgbtq plus rights
and political issues the mob of
right-wing polls attacked a pride March
in the town of bialistoc one of several
districts that have declared themselves
to be lgbt-free according to Freedom
House Nationalist and discriminatory
rhetoric had grown and the government
enacted numerous measures that have
damaged Poland's Democratic progress
both major parties blame social media
for worsening Poland's political
polarization and called the situation
unsustainable
Poland's far-right Confederation party
had the biggest Facebook presence even
though it only had a few seats in
Parliament
tomage kobachik the party's social media
director told the Washington Post that
Facebook was a hate algorithm and his
party did well with emotional messages
one party leader summarized its platform
saying we don't want Jews homosexuals
abortion taxes and the European Union
the Confederation party won 11 seats in
the 2019 parliamentary election despite
not expecting to win any
grubarchik credited his party's online
efforts explaining we did everything on
the internet everything I'd say it's 70
thanks to Facebook
removed the page of one of the
Confederation leaders in 2020 and later
banned the entire party for repeated
violations of its standards on covid-19
disinformation and hate speech a
confederation party leader criticized
Metta saying an American corporation
wants to suppress freedom of debate and
interfere with democracy and the
electoral process in Poland and called
on the government to pass a proposed law
to stop quote totalitarian censorship by
social media companies prime minister
matteus moraviesky of the law and
Justice party had previously compared
censorship by social media companies to
the authoritarian regimes that once
ruled his country in a 2021 Facebook
post he wrote We Lived in a censored
country for nearly 50 years a country
where big brother told us what we don't
have the right to think to say to right
that is why we look with concern at any
attempts to limit freedom a byword for
Freedom has always been the internet the
most democratic medium in history
gradually large transnational
corporations richer and more powerful
than many countries have started to
dominate
Poland will always uphold Democratic
Values including freedom of speech
social media cannot act above the law
therefore we will do all we can to set
out a framework for the functioning of
Facebook Twitter Instagram and other
similar platforms
[Music]
in April 2021 Facebook instituted
changes to give users more Choice over
their news feeds including a most recent
mode where new posts appeared first and
the ability to prioritize up to 30
friends or pages
Facebook feed P Clegg told NPR that
quote everybody accepts that new rules
of the road need to be written and
explain the new features during an
interview what I announced in this
article is some additional controls
which give people real transparency in
how the systems work and allows people
to pull levers so for instance you know
in a new feature which I announced today
you'll be able to in effect override the
algorithm and curate your own your own
news feed in October 2021 the Facebook
company officially changed its name to
meta it framed the rebranding as a shift
in Focus toward building a virtual world
called the metaverse but the new name
hasn't quieted the debate over social
media's role as a platform for political
speech
on January 25th 2023 a few months after
Twitter reactivated president Trump's
account meta announced it would do the
same ending its suspension of trump and
reinstating him on Facebook and
Instagram in a written statement the
company said in light of Trump's
violations he will also face heightened
penalties for repeat offenses it
continued we believe it is both
necessary and possible to draw a line
between content that is harmful and
should be removed and content that
however it is tasteful or inaccurate is
part of the Rough and Tumble of life in
a free Society
foreign
[Music]
we hope the information in this podcast
helps you understand how political
speech and social media intersect our
goal is to spark conversations and ideas
about business ethics and businesses
role in society this podcast was based
on the original written case titled
Facebook and political speech written by
Ken Schatz professor of political
economy at Stanford Graduate School of
Business and case writer Sheila Melvin
it was produced by Andrew Stelzer and
Pablo woy thaler I'm Kelsey Doyle and
I'm Jenny Luna thanks for listening
foreign